welcome hmm oops welcome to this video
Dexter Morgan yeah I played him before
when he played a very weird opening
losing quickly I had this is now now
it's time for a super solid stuff let's
see you Bishop f4 quince can be declined
okay is going for b6 now that's a good
line especially if you want to have a
little bit of a fighting position with
black v6 okay so I'm just going to keep
it simple here let's see Queenie to or
take first I am Not sure I can also take
it first okay now maybe rook c 1 i'm not
sure if I want to play Queenie to the
Queen normally goes there Abbott here
maybe Queen a4 is also an idea this is a
typical position with hanging pawns d5
and see 595 my bishop should be only 2
a.m. that's not a great position I
wonder how nighty fibers kind of normal
centralizing I might have defied some
point it's okay it should be ok anyway
and centralizing this piece okay I
thought this should be okay I so archaic
Anakin you can play Bishop to c6 ok this
is still quite ok for him I see Queen a
form a BM and say in general traits are
our welcome welcome to me those points
usually get weaker if more pieces i
exchanged so I do mind mind some trades
important this that he never really has
rock PA due to this Bishop hem ok I can
take home is playing very quickly not
quite sure why
so any need to hurry queen bee three
yeah maybe Mac we can go group b six and
that's but it's not helping me much
Bishop g5 has also moved increasing the
pressure on d5 Jim I don't know rook da
tore something I mean I can take maybe
just on a 70 k 6 Queen B seven that
looks a bit tricky
yeah that's possible I said the big
pre-move kingdom who is entering
pre-move I'm threatening 95 now winning
this pawn and it's also a big a big Fork
okay so Quinn 2g phone can I take c5r
okay too
hmm it's not a bad position I can also
do this
maybe I should have taken there
immediately probably what's better
somehow bring a sore throat him come on
let's let's trade this note and I cannot
take here whatever reason I don't know
why I cannot take
and yeah what do we add player what is
really high rated young quite strange
okay takes so let's think about it
what's the best possible setup cannot
take unfortunately here this route d6
coming efore is running into earned into
trouble so i have to prepare you for
so the time time is the real issue time
warning ok trying to simplify matters
Knight to c4 ok 53 seconds not good
check check this is linda c 4 i'm not
good okay check check check check rook
g5 check made check late and she ignored
surprisingly ignored I mean okay I was
winning anyway I guess but still made
his mate is made yeah I don't know i
don't understand what this guy is doing
so mostly just playing yeah pre moves
and whatnot in situation where it's not
think i don't know ok let's have a look
mm-hmm it was not much happening around
here i think this is about equal i was
trading off some stuff but it still
keeps everything within equal territory
i have some pressure now on d5 and went
here here yeah i know i went with this
yeah quincy fire interesting i could
have taken by drug takes 90 3 i'm not
sure how much this is it's not bad for
white but it's also not a position where
i can hope for very much
this is simply active now that's okay
for black ok so I went here and no
actually the computer is giving me ugh
am already and I can take now which I
didn't do yeah i was playing h3 a bit
too quickly thinking ok let's do
something for the background and some
but i can really just take the pawn then
one point is that i have this move and
then before who's just a pawn yeah it's
better but for some reason here I mean
it just has to take of course here and
in this position I think I don't know if
this is anything for what if anybody
white is better because of those points
that has slightly under pressure but
it's nothing serious compass on 0.1
something and this is just blundering
yeah I think from a technical point of
view I played it ok up to a certain
degree but then all the pre moves took
its toll took their toll before is
strong here for example lab before us
just winning threatening b.tech c5 yeah
that's easy ok and here again be four
was winning check now yet Bishop f2 but
ok this guy is not playing playing for
proper chest check is just playing pre
moves and everything quickly and so on
so not try to to win even check here I'm
again better check around here chats
tricky because he got himself into this
position on the edge of the board yeah
made sure and this is just winning him
you can't play rook air-five to prolong
metals but it's just a one end game ok
thanks for watching